what yeah What ethnicity probably has
the worst smelling garbage it was all
the same it was all the it's garbage man
once you throw it in there it's all
Blended in and like you said during the
Summers it was it was grueling like
people would walk by like covering their
faces like that's how bad the truck melt
sometimes I once you're in it you don't
know anymore you you don't smell nothing
anymore you get used to it huh so used
to it cat cat YN was the worse for me oh
it was awful cuz it would you would rub
up on a bag that a cat just pissed on
mhm and like yeah like you were saying
with the truck now we we get in me and
my partner and I I know like bag stayed
far away from me yeah you know I'm big
enough guy long enough arms I kept that
[__] away I never let the bags touch my
legs and I would look at my pond I'm
like you got hit and he's like what do
you mean I said you don't smell that cuz
now you get in it's even cold out you
close the doors put the heat on and you
smell that turn cat piss up you know oh
yeah oh yeah yeah disgusting it's the
worst smell out there yeah I remember we
to get a bowl of cat piss and uh we
would do a hair dryer over it bro just
to [__] piss my sister off do it
under the door by her room [__] her dude
awful [__] her um wow so there's no time
a year really when the trash smells
worse huh well the Summer's a bit just
the Summer's overall but yeah it's you
know there was some point you know you
would open up a lid and if it was
sitting there with maggots and stuff you
you get a kick mhm and that's another
smell that was pretty brutal but other
than that it's you got used to it like
that reminds me of the time I smell a
skunk I'm like what the [__] is that
smell in the back of the truck like
that's something odd so now I could
smell it and there was like a skunk in
like a little path mark bag like that we
used to call them like the little
plastic bags tied up and everything and
I'm thinking to myself like who the [__]
took the time to grab this skunk kill it
and then put it in a bag yeah it's like
what people ain't right to even think of
doing that like who's playing with
skunks like was there a burrow of New
York where the trash smelled the worst
you think no okay all the same stand out
there was a movie theater not far from
the dump before they closed it it was
awful the smell and they were building
houses like crazy right there I'm like
how could people buy and then I became a
garbage man and like then I don't smell
it no
more stand out don't smell no more cuz
we would get you know [__] on all the
time by Le burough yeah uh you know
trash island you know all that but you
just didn't smell it could you smell
different types of trash from certain
amounts of feet away you know what it is
the maggot smell like I was saying is
the killer you know and there are
sometimes I I have a backyard you know
that we eat outside we throw the garbage
and I don't throw it out right away it's
like in a bag in a pal M dude maggots
will start crawling out of the pale
maggots are gross huh hate aw
I used to be walking around there all my
arms they would they would come out of
the truck Splat on your like nasty like
blowing them off your arm while you're
on the back of the truck it's part of
the job was there like a wave of trash
water that would come out on the
cycle like I'm see I'm talking something
Kelly Kelly Slater would flirt with you
know so this so this woman and I knew
her from the neighborhood I went to
school well I didn't go to school with
her daughter but I knew her daughter
from high school MH and I used to hang
out with her and her friends and she
comes out she's like oh Wayne I got can
I can't lift the sofa and it was in the
driveway I'm like yeah I'll get it go
back inside down porn so we throw the
sofa in and we throw bags in now she's
right next to me and I'm like don't
stand there go somewhere else no no no
no I want to get she's trying to help
give us something you know for taking
this Stu let me give you a couple
muffins or something it's Cycles dude
from head to toe it was brown Water she
literally had maggots like on her face I
was like get in the house yeah and go
take a shower she's like what is all
this I was with her eyes closed oh I'm
like just get in the [__] house I
told you don't stand here you know
that's the Devil's Back wash I me you
don't want that it just happened because
we were uphill and and the rainy days
now you're lifting every pale that
doesn't have a lid water's going in and
it's just squashing around it's it's
like sewage oh it's
disgusting dude I did this game one day
and I went in New York right down I went
in the city like I think I was on the
Lower East
Side and I did this game with people I
said I'mma open a bag of trash you smell
it you take a whiff out of it right just
a random bag okay and if you can guess
three items that are inent it I give you
a hundred bucks right so dude so these
people they all thought I was like that
the bags I had like brought them from
home or something put them together
whatever I was picking these [__] up
from the [__] corner didn't even know
if they would be right bro I had no idea
what was in them dude so we had people
we crack them back and [__] people are
taking hits off of it dude over there
off of an alphabet City bro that was
nasty stuff down
there